entschuldigung ich weiß es nervt aber
bevor wir weiter machen in der sendung
muss sich jetzt von jedem einzelnen
zuschauer hier leider eine
datenschutzerklärung einholen ja ja sie
wissen schon wegen dieser blöden neuen
eu-verordnung fahren wir mal hier bei
wem man hier bei ihnen fangen wir mal an
sehen sie damit einverstanden über alle
gags zu lachen die heute schon bei
facebook zu liken und lebenslang
rundfunkgebühren zu bezahlen
er will soll sich tag x jahr für sie ein
das geht schneller so und versprechen
sie keine beschwerdebriefe mir das zdf
zu schreiben weil sascha hehn als
traumschiff -kapitän schmeißt ja mein
gott vater kein bock mehr wir können ihn
nicht zwingen so die anderen mache ich
nach der seite seit letzter woche gilt
die neue datenschutz grund verordnung
der eu kurz dsgv dahinter steht eine
verrückte idee was wenn wir als bürger
selber bestimmen können was mit unseren
daten passiert auf so bekloppte sache
kommt wirklich nur die eu in deutschland
wird direkt wieder gemeckert ein
bürokratischer albtraum heißt es da zum
beispiel für becker die bäcker kommen
jetzt gar nicht mehr zum backen die neue
eu datenschutz grund verordnen hält ihn
auf trab
also es kommt zu einer seine
verrücktheiten hinzu dass ich jetzt
aussehen muss eine datenschutzerklärung
für unsere kunden dass unsere kunden
sich durch lesen können was passiert
dann mit ihren daten in meinem betrieb
es wird niemand interessieren aber ich
muss es aussehen
er muss das ausdrucken und aufhängen da
ist der halbe tag schon rom
deswegen schmecken wie brötchen moment
so salzig wegen der tränen der bäcker
und das sind nicht die einzigen opfer
des datenschutzes in die kantine im
landesfunkhaus hannover
wer geburtstag hatte bekam hier an der
kasse immer eine kleine aufmerksamkeit
versehen mit name und geburtsdatum des
jubilars
doch damit ist jetzt schluss ja solche
wollte ich nicht ich denke mein
mitarbeiter nie was zum geburtstag
gegen datenschutz sechs jahre hat die eu
an dieser datenschutz verordnung
getüftelt sechs jahre für firmen die
illegale daten geschäfte machen sind bis
zu 20 millionen euro strafe drin ist
doch prima natürlich gibt es wie immer
auch ein paar nervige nebenwirkungen bei
instagram werden gerade zum beispiel
reihenweise die accounts von unter
16-jährigen gelöscht ohne zustimmung der
eltern geht nichts mehr
das erklärt warum man gerade so viele
verzweifelte teenager entgegenkommen und
die armen streunen völlig verwirrt durch
die straßen viele waren ja noch nie in
der realen welt wundert sich jetzt über
diese total realistische 3d grafik
überlegen sie mal was sollen die armen
menschen machen den ganzen tag
misstrauen
[Applaus]
nur ganz mittel
vielen dank
schlimm apropos datenschutz haben sie
das noch nicht mitgekriegt es ist
tatsächlich ein völlig neues bislang
unbekanntes otfried preußler buch
aufgetaucht und zwar der daten räuber
hotzenplotz kapitel eins ohne ihn ruft
die großmutter der hotzenplotz wird es
etwa schon wieder mal eine kaffeemühle
klauen und er so scheiß auf die mühle
daten her du alle ziegel sagt kopiert er
sich omas facebook und inder daten und
macht mit ihr ein letztes l v8 beruf der
hotzenblitz großmutters datenverkauf ich
jetzt an den bösen zauberer petrosilius
zuckerberg aber der ruf bist du blöd ich
habe noch längst alle daten begrenzt die
wähler rotzen göde mir gehört facebook
traurig zieht der doofe räuber hat und
dann lagern ihn auch noch der eu kasper
und der us apple voll wird mal wir haben
eine neue datenschutz grund verordnung
jetzt muss der arme hotzenplotz nach
jedem datenklau so viele formulare
ausfüllen das hat gar keinen bock mehr
hat deswegen macht er jetzt was
anständiges und verkauft wieder heroin
vor der grundschule
verschollenes hotzenplotz wieder
aufgetaucht so jetzt aber die schlechte
nachricht leider profitiert ausgerechnet
petrosilius zuckerberg von diesen neuen
datenschutz hat er wieder eine lücke
entdeckt facebook und whatsapp tauschen
jetzt wieder ihre daten aus in
deutschland war das bislang verboten
aber jetzt ist ja plötzlich brüssel
zuständig immerhin hat es die eu aber
geschafft mark zuckerberg vorzuladen
es folgt ein stolzer moment und
wahrscheinlich der witz der woche die
präsenz von mark zuckerberg im
europäischen parlament zeigt dass
facebook respekt und angst vom
europäischen gesetzgeber hat klar dass
nicht ein warum sollte der angst haben
vor einem kontinent den nicht mal
zwingend steuern zu zahlen nur 80
minuten hat zuckerberg den
eu-parlamentariern gegönnt nur 80
minuten aber wieder weg es ging ratzfatz
und leider leider ist jetzt auch kein
witz haben die fragen der abgeordneten
brüssel
60 dieser 80 minuten in anspruch
genommen ja ist ja unglaublich da hat
man einmal die chance den sack am berg
zu grillen und da kommen solche fragen
hier
achten sie mal auf seinen blick um
beispielsweise auch mit mit goethe und
seinem zauberlehrling zu sprechen
herr die not ist groß die ich rief die
geister werd ich nicht mehr los ist es
zeit den stecker zu ziehen
[Applaus]
danach danach hat sie ihm noch die
gesammelten werke von rilke vorgelesen
ja ja leider leider konnte ackerbürger
in der kurzen zeit nur die wenigsten
fragen beantworten aber er hat
versprochen die anderen schriftlich
nachzureichen ja die liegen jetzt schon
in seinem büro auf wiedervorlage
da kann man sich drauf verlassen meine
damen und herren weil da so wahnsinnig
viel respekt und angst hat vor der eu
die neue datenschutz verordnung reden
wir drüber mit einer digital native
hazel broker meldet sich live aus dem
internet hallo ich bin im internet ja
ich sehe ist toll wie viele deutsche
sagen wenn es um datenschutz im netz
geht mir völlig egal ich habe nichts zu
verbergen
ja gut also erstens geben leute die
sowas sagen wenn die sagen dass sie
nichts zu verbergen haben dann geben die
einfach damit an wie langweilig ihr
leben ist und zweitens nur weil man sich
für etwas nicht stimmt heißt das noch
lange nicht dass er es auch jeder sehen
können sollte jeder der schon mal eine
rentnergruppe am fkk strand von
hiddensee gesehen hat weiß genau wovon
ich spreche
leider ja wie wirkt sich denn das neue
gesetz auf den kunden aus na ja im
moment nerven ja vor allem die ganzen
newsletter die darum betteln dass man
sie weiterhin abonniert zwecks
kundenbindung früher hat man ja was
gekauft dann war man kunde und wenn man
fertig war mit kauf und dann war man
nicht mehr kunde heute kauft man was und
danach ist man einfach immer weiter
kunde da muss man noch teil einer
community werden sich ein membership
namen ausdenken an membership passwort
bei den ersten drei passwörtern denkt
man sich dann so was sonderzeichen sie
nicht nur erlaubt sondern sogar
erwünscht und nach dem dritten mal denkt
man sich da nur noch wackelt hazel 123
wer sie probieren das da und man kann
dann gar nicht mehr aufhören kunde zu
sein man muss eine bewertung abgeben
eine meinung zum produkt haben ich habe
aber eigentlich nie eine meinung zu den
produkten die ich kaufe wenn ich mir zum
beispiel ein bahnticket kaufen online
weil ich interagieren sicher nicht
freiwillig mit jemandem der sich dazu
entschieden hat sein leben am schalter
deutschen bahn zu verbringen
wenn ich mir also ein bahnticket kaufen
von zürich nach köln dann hat der
kaufprozess nicht damit auf dass sich
das ticket gekauft habe der kauf ist
nicht mal dann vorbei wenn ich in köln
aus dem zug aussteigen ein
ich kriege dann noch ein dutzend e mails
von der deutschen bahn dem ich belästigt
und fragt wie fanden sie denn ihre
zugfahrt von zürich nach köln und wie
fanden sie den unsere e mail bezüglich
ihrer zugfahrt von zürich nach keine
ahnung ich erwarte nichts von einer
bahnfahrt ich habe keine meinung zu
einer bahnfahrt ich verstehe auch die
leute nicht die sich immer über die
deutsche bahn aufregen was erwarten die
sind sie enttäuscht dass sie nicht auf
der höhe von karlsruhe ein
bachelor-abschluss gekriegt haben also
wenn ich von zürich nach köln fahren
dann erwarte ich einfach dass ich
irgendwo in der nähe von zürich
einsteige maximal schritttempo schneller
kann ich nicht laufen sorry deswegen
braucht er den zug und dann wünsche ich
mir dass ich in einer ähnlichen
jahreszeit nicht in der selben
jahreszeit einfach in einer ähnlichen
jahreszeit damit ich meine passion sense
während der fahrt nicht komplett
überdenken muss in einer ähnlichen
jahreszeit in der nähe von köln zwischen
werder und bilbao genügt
aussteiger und nicht aids habe und das
versteht die deutsche waren einfach
nicht ja jetzt muss man zugeben so
wichtig datenschutz ist die meisten
menschen nutzen das internet
hauptsächlich um sich irgendwelche
idiotischen sachen hin und her zu
schicken so was wie das hier so meine
frage dürfte ich dir so ein video nach
der neuen daten verordnung überhaupt
noch schicken ja bei katzen ist es zum
glück sehr unkompliziert falls die katze
klagt schmeißt man sie einfach aus dem
nächsten fenster
sie hat ja dann noch acht leben übrig
und für jedes leben gelten neue
datenschutzgesetz
natürlich helfen
[Applaus]